[Music]
well hockey season is here the vegas
golden knights kick off the
2021 season this week they have home
games at t-mobile against the anaheim
ducks
on thursday the 14th and saturday the
16th
then two more games home games against
the arizona coyotes on monday and
wednesday
then they head to arizona on friday
and in february the knights will take to
the ice
outdoors they will be the first for the
team sports director chris matthews is
in the newsroom with details on the
match-up chris well thank you very much
yeah it's now official what was rumored
for a few weeks confirmed by the nhl
today
and vegas will be part of that unique
event commissioner gary bettman
talking prior to the opening of the 2021
nhl season
and he confirmed that the vegas golden
knights will spend a night
in lake tahoe and play hockey on a rink
set up
on a fairway at the edwards golf course
the commissioner providing all the
details
it's all great news except for the one
part that says no fans
this is the nhl outdoors at lake tahoe
and we couldn't be more excited about
the opportunity
to put on a major event even though
we're not going to be able to have fans
but if you look at the picture the
setting is going to be spectacular
for us to be outdoors the game on
february 20th on saturday will involve
vegas and colorado we're not going to be
having fans there obviously
but that's the point of having a major
event
that will give us a spectacular visual
have a fun opportunity for the players
to once again play outdoors
which they tell us they love and
tahoe fit the bill oh it certainly is
beautiful and it certainly was yeah the
game will be coming up in february but
this thursday the vegas gold knights
open their season
against the anaheim ducks we'll see if
the governor has any
new mandates on allowing a certain
percentage of fans at sporting events
here in southern nevada
three teams in the league are allowing
fans right now arizona florida
and dallas possibly columbus also
kirsten all right we